Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Es wird allerhöchste Zeit, mal wieder auf die europäischen Top-Ligen zu gucken. Herzlich willkommen zur Rasenfunk Ligatour. Heute mit Spanien, Frankreich, Italien und wen hab ich denn vergessen? Mensch, das geht ja ganz grandios. Los, ich krieg nicht mal die vier Ligen zusammen, über die wir sprechen wollen, aber ihr habt ihn schon gehört. David Frogier de Ponlevoy von 390 ist mal wieder mit dabei und er hat mich gerettet, also England war die vierte Liga. Hallo David und ebenfalls mit dabei sind Christian Bernhard für die Serie A, Fabian Pakulat für die Spanische La Liga und Hendrik Buchheister für die Premier League. Ihr seht schon, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, die größte Herausforderung heute wird so halbwegs ein bisschen in der Kurzpasszeit noch zu bleiben, deswegen gar keine große Begrüßungsorgie, sondern wir legen direkt los. Wir gucken als Allererstes in die Spanische Liga, auf La Liga. Da haben wir in der letzten Ligatur, die ziemlich genau einen Monat her ist, haben wir da, Fabian, viel über Barca sprechen müssen eigentlich schon, ein bisschen über Real. Alles andere ging dann schon so ein bisschen unter. Deswegen bin ich gespannt, über was würdest du denn gerne sprechen? Was hat sich denn jetzt nach fünf gespielten Spieltagen getan?
Ja, Barca können wir wahrscheinlich nicht ganz weglassen, vor allen Dingen nach dem Spiel gestern auch oder nach dem 0-3 in der Champions League gegen die Bayern. Da ist allgemein der Adalaz ziemlich groß. Die spanische Liga hat, glaube ich, allgemein sehr verloren jetzt nach dieser Pandemie. Oder wir sind ja noch in der Pandemie, aber nach diesem extremen Covid-Jahr ohne Zuschauer. Und das spürt man eigentlich durchweg. Ich denke aber, insgesamt macht es die Liga ein bisschen spannender, ein bisschen ausgeglichener. Und ja, ich bin eigentlich ganz guter Dinge, dass es eine relativ spannende Saison wird, auch wenn real schon wieder so ein bisschen davon zieht. Aber auch die sehe ich nicht so sattelfest wie zum Beispiel die letzten Jahre. Und ja, es gibt ja auch das ein oder andere Team von hinten, das ganz Interessantes. Also ich denke, die Liga ist wesentlich ausgeglichen als die letzten Jahre.
Also nachdem du mit Barca begonnen hast und nicht alle wissen, dass das letzte Spiel, das du angesprochen hast, das war ein 1 zu 1 gegen Granada. Es war eine herausragende Partie, was die Flanken angeht. 54 Flanken hat Barca geschlagen. Ich wiederhole, das ist keine Übung. 54 Flanken. Allein deshalb werde ich dieses Spiel nie sehen. Es ging 1 zu 1 aus. Es gab allerdings auch ein klares Verhältnis in den Abschlüssen. Also 17 zu 5 Schüsse. Wenn wir jetzt einfach nur die letzten Partien angucken, dann scheint sich das aber halt in so ein Bild einzureihen. Diese dann doch deutliche Niederlage gegen die Bayern in der Champions League unter der Woche. Jetzt eben nur ein 1 zu 1 gegen Granada. Damit hat man jetzt schon 5 Punkte Rückstand auf Real Madrid, die an der Tabellenspitze sind. Du hast jetzt ja quasi schon die Auswirkungen auf den Rest der Liga klar gemacht. Es könnte spannender werden. Ist denn die Lage bei Barca so dramatisch, wie es sich jetzt auch in der Champions League angefühlt hat, als wäre da eine Ära zu Ende gegangen? Und das würde jetzt mindestens ein Übergangsjahr werden?
Ich fürchte fast schon. Ich hatte am Anfang der Saison noch relativ gute Dinge nach dem ersten Saisonspiel gegen Real Sociedad San Sebastian. Das hat mir ziemlich gut gefallen. Da war aber auch noch Grießmann dabei. Ich hatte so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass der Weggang von Messi vielleicht jetzt endlich Spieler wie Grießmann oder auch die anderen Neuzugänge, die jetzt da noch gekommen sind, ein bisschen freier macht, und dass die sich ein bisschen mehr entfalten können. Im Endeffekt muss man aber jetzt auch, wenn man auf den Kader von Barca schaut, schon deutlich sagen, dass da die Breite vor allen Dingen fehlt. Im Mittelfeld finde ich es ganz brutal. Dazu kommen natürlich noch viele Verletzte. Und Trainer Kummer macht auch gerade keine glückliche Figur, entschuldigt sich für seine für sein flanken Spiel dadurch, im Endeffekt, dass er sagt, ich habe im Moment nichts anderes, mit dem ich zum Beispiel Tiki-Taka-Fußball spielen könnte.
Er hat doch auch noch Tiki-Taka falsch gesagt. Hat er nicht irgendwie Tiki-Tiki oder irgendwas? Das ist ganz seltsam.
Tiki-Taki hat er gesagt.
Ja, genau. Ich glaube, da macht man sich auch Freunde in Barcelona, wenn man nicht mal das hinkriegt.
Da macht man sich Freunde. Er ist ja auch schon ziemlich lange eigentlich in Barcelona oder in Spanien tätig und sollte eigentlich ein bisschen besser sprechen. Das klappt nicht so ganz bei ihm.
Okay, also bei Barca haben wir Baustellen in jedem Fall. Dann, du hast schon Real kurz angesprochen. Real zieht ein bisschen davon. Hast du es genannt als eine von ein paar Mannschaften, zwar noch ungeschlagen, aber die einzige, die schon vier Siege einfahren konnte. Das heißt aktuell 13 Punkte, 15 zu sieben Tore. Und das, obwohl ja so mancher Transfer dann doch gar nicht geklappt hat. Wie würdest du denn die Lage da einschätzen?
Also ich muss sagen, Real Madrid beeindruckt mich tatsächlich. Jetzt in dieser Anfangsphase hätte ich so auch nicht erwartet. Gestern oder vorgestern beziehungsweise das Spiel gegen Valencia. Das sah aus lange Zeit eigentlich nicht so gut aus für die Königlichen. Valencia war 1-0 vorne. Aber Real hat das Ding noch in der Schlussphase gedreht. Und zwar muss ich sagen, wie gesagt, sehr eindrucksvoll, mit einer tollen Teamleistung. Und die haben da vorne mit Benzema natürlich einen, was ein Lewandowski für die Bayern ist. Also der macht einfach da vorne, was er will und spielt unwahrscheinlich gut. Und mannschaftsdienlich auch, macht seine Dinger. Und dann gibt es ja noch diesen Vinicius, der dieses Jahr tatsächlich den Anschein hat, dass er jetzt endlich durchstartet. Also ich glaube, 4-5 Tore hat er schon geschossen und macht tatsächlich wichtige Treffer wie immer. Auch das 1 zu 1 gegen Valencia. Das 2 zu 1 hat er vorbereitet mit einer Flanke auf Benzema. Also wundert mich doch auch immer wieder, wie dann doch Angelotti, der ja eigentlich so eher der alten Trainerschule angehört, zu Real Madrid einfach passt wie die Faust aus dem Auge. Und ja, das sieht relativ gut aus, obwohl auch Real Madrid natürlich einen heftigen Adalaz hatte mit Spielerverkäufen, also vor allen Dingen die Abwehr. Gefällt mir eigentlich gar nicht bei den Königlichen. Das wackelt noch sehr. Aber sie machen es im Moment vorneweg. Sie haben ja auch schon 7 Tore kassiert, aber eben auch 15 geschossen.
Und ich habe gehört, Kamal Winger hat sich gut eingefügt direkt.
Absolut. Also ich meine, dass der gut kicken kann, das haben wir alle gesehen. Jetzt habe ich gestern mit einem Freund gesprochen. Das hatte eigentlich auch jeder damals von Renato Sanches gedacht, der dann zu Bayern gewechselt ist und da nicht so durchgestartet ist. Nein, aber Kamal Winger macht das ziemlich gut. Und ich denke, das war ein Last-Minute-Transfer der obersten Klasse. Also da wird sich Real Madrid noch freuen. Und das wäre eigentlich genau ein Spieler gewesen, der Barca gut getan hätte, weil Barca hat im Mittelfeld, wie gesagt, bis auf Franck Ideon ganz wenig im Moment zu bieten. Und Real Madrid hat jetzt tatsächlich Alternativen. Wenn Modric und Kroos sind in die Jahre gekommen oder verletzt sind, dann ist da Federico Valverde, da ist da dieser junge Camavinga. Die Königlichen haben das ganz ordentlich gemacht, muss man sagen.
Also für alle diejenigen, die das nicht mitbekommen haben, Eduardo Camavinga ist von Ren zu Real Madrid gewechselt, noch vor Ende der Transfer-Fensterschließung. Anders wäre es ja auch nicht möglich gewesen, lieber Max, sinnlos das so zu erwähnen.
Eines dieser ganz jungen Talente, der schon vor zwei Jahren auf sich Aufmerksam gemacht hat in Frankreich, letztes Jahr ein bisschen abgetaucht ist bei Rennen, die vom Trainer nicht mal eingesetzt worden sind. Alle haben sich gefragt, was wird mit dem. Freut mich sehr, dass der jetzt ausgerechnet bei Real groß aufspielt.
Das könnte ganz gut passen. Ich möchte nur noch einmal kurz das unterstreichen, was du gesagt hast, Fabian, zu Karim Benzema. Du hast gesagt, er ist das, was Lewandowski für die Bayern ist. Sechs Tore schon erzielt, fünf vorbereitet. Das heißt, 11 Torbeteiligungen und arg viel mehr Tore hat Real in dem Pflichtspiel bisher noch nicht geschossen. Das sind nämlich 15 insgesamt. Das sind schon einfach irre Zahlen. Man hat auch in der Champions League gegen Inter Mailand gewinnen können, wenn auch sehr last minute, aber Auswärtssieg. Das heißt, das lässt sich alles gut bei Real an. Jetzt wollen wir aber ja wahrscheinlich nicht nur über die großen 2 oder vielleicht auch die großen 3, Athletik haben wir jetzt noch nicht genannt, sprechen. Was würdest du sagen, ist noch wichtig zu wissen zu La Liga?
Vielleicht doch ganz kurz ein kleiner Abschwenker zu Benzema. Dem hat es richtig gut getan, dass Ronaldo Real Madrid verlassen hat. Dementsprechend hatte ich auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass wenn Messi Barca verlässt, dass dort andere Spieler aus dem Schatten sozusagen treten wie Griezmann, der dann aber verkauft worden ist aufgrund der heiklen finanziellen Lage. Dementsprechend war das wahrscheinlich ganz gut für Benzema, dass eben Ronaldo da vor zwei Jahren oder sogar schon drei Jahre verkauft worden ist. Aber gut, lassen wir die Königlichen aber bei der Seite und schauen uns mal den Rest der Liga an. Ich finde sehr interessant die Entwicklung der beiden baskischen Clubs. Real Sociedad San Sebastian, die machen das eigentlich schon die letzten zwei, drei Jahre richtig gut. Und auch Athletic Club Bilbao, da sehe ich dieses Jahr ziemlich stark, sie haben noch kein Spiel verloren. Haben mit Trainer Marcelino einen, der ja eher so für die, obwohl er schon länger im Geschäft ist, aber eher so für die jüngere Gilde der Trainer steht, mit einem sehr erfrischenden Offensivfußball normalerweise, hohem Pressing und der hat da richtig was zusammengeformt. Also Bilbao habe ich so für die Plätze 6 bis 8 auf jeden Fall auch im Köcher. Und dann war natürlich am Wochenende eine schöne Schlagzeile in den spanischen Medien. Die Rückkehr von Farcao in La Liga und ausgerechnet zum Club-Reihe Valle Cano. Das ist sowas wie, ich würde mal behaupten sowas wie St. Pauli, das St. Pauli Spaniens. Und ein sehr sympathischer Club. Und da ist jetzt Farcao gewechselt und gleich in seinem ersten Spiel nach der Einwechslung ein Tor vorbereitet, eins erzielt. Und Valle Cano hat auch einen sehr jungen und muss ich sagen sehr interessanten Trainer mit Andoni Iraola. Der war lange Jahre Rechtsverteidiger von Athletic Bilbao. War es eigentlich so sportlich so eine Art Philipp Lahm. Der hat immer relativ unspektakulär aus seiner rechten Außenbahn gespielt, war aber einer, der eigentlich nie Fehler gemacht hat. Und der ist jetzt seit zwei, drei Jahren Trainer, hat in der ersten Zweitliga-Saison mit Mirandez einen ziemlich guten Job gemacht. In der zweiten Saison ist er zu Valle Cano, hat dort letztes Jahr den Aufstieg geschafft. Obwohl sie nur auf Platz 6 gekommen sind, haben sie sich in den Playoffs durchgesetzt und die stehen im Moment auf Platz 10. Wie gesagt, sie spielen einen sehr erfrischenden Fußball und sind mit Sicherheit eine Bereicherung für die Liga dieses Jahr.
Okay, da muss ich jetzt, wenn du einen lahmquäl vergleichst, natürlich eine alles entscheidende Frage stellen. Ist er denn auch auf Social Media so spritzig wie unser ehemaliger Weltmeister Kapitän?
Ich würde sagen, außerhalb des Platzes haben sie sehr wenig gemeint. Aber ich glaube, Irola ist auf Social Media gar nicht aktiv. Nein, er ist ein sehr zurückhaltender Mann. Das war er auch schon auf dem Platz. Aber ein sehr hoher Fußballsachverstand. Und das gibt wunderbar seinem Team weiter.
Und das mit der Falcao-Rücke. Also Radamel Falcao für diejenigen Hörerinnen und Hörer, die sich das gefragt haben. 35 Jahre ist er inzwischen alt. Wie passt denn das zusammen? Du hast ja gerade bei Bebao gesagt, junger Trainer, offensiver Fußball, hohes Pressing, auch eher eine jüngere Mannschaft. Bei Cano scheint es mir ein bisschen gemischter zu sein, ohne da jetzt aber genau zu wissen, wer wie viel Spielzeit schon hatte. Gibt es da einen Unterschied zu Bebao?
Ja, du hast schon recht, das Team ist ein bisschen gemischter. Ich würde auch sagen, dass Rio definitiv noch mal offensiv definitiv mehr macht und mehr riskiert und höher steht. Bebao ist da wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen konservativer, ein bisschen mehr noch auf Absicherung bedacht. Das war auch schon letztes Jahr in der Zweitliga-Saison bei Valle Cano zu sehen. Die waren tatsächlich vorne immer unterwegs, hinten natürlich immer offen wie ein Scheuentor. Aber das ist Iraola in dem Fall egal. Mir ist es wichtiger, vorne ein Tor mehr zu erzielen. Dementsprechend ist dort Spektakel geboten. Wie gesagt, dieses kleine Stadion im Madrid-Stadtteil Vallecas, da ist immer eine richtig geile Stimmung, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf. Und jetzt natürlich, mit der Spielweise, passt das wunderbar zusammen.
Das darfst du auf jeden Fall so sagen. Ich finde es ganz interessant, wenn ich mir die Tabelle nach fünf Spieltagen angucke, dann bekommst du ja schon eine gewisse Relevanz. Da haben wir bis zum Tabellenplatz 13, da liegt Cadiz, haben wir Mannschaften, die es immerhin einmal geschafft haben, zu gewinnen in den bisherigen fünf Spielen. Es gibt auch noch Mannschaften, die zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme nur vier Spiele haben. Unter anderem Villarreal, die haben bisher vier Mal unentschieden gespielt. Dann kommen aber nur Mannschaften, die bisher immer verloren haben oder häufiger verloren haben, plus unentschieden gespielt haben. Ist das stellvertretend für eine Zweiteilung der Liga? Ist das jetzt einfach ein statistischer Zufall durch den Spielplan geschuldet? Kann man da was reininterpretieren?
Ich würde vor allen Dingen die letzten zwei, also Getafe und Deportivo a la Vez, die sehe ich dieses Jahr extrem schwach. Bei den anderen sehe ich noch ziemlich viel Potenzial und unentschiedene oder unglückliche Niederlagen. Aber die zwei da unten, die machen mir tatsächlich Sorgen, weil da kommt ganz, ganz wenig. Trainer Mitchell von Getafe und auch Javi Carrejo von a la Vez, die sind schon stark angezählt. Da würde ich mich nicht wundern, wenn da die nächsten Tage oder spätestens dann eben nächste Woche was passiert. Wir haben ja jetzt Englische Woche in Spanien, heute geht es gleich weiter. Ich denke, das werden schon die Schicksalsspiele sein für diese zwei Trainer. Und vielleicht auch schon für Ronald Kummer bei Barca, denn der ist auch schon ziemlich heftig angezählt.
Ach ja, Barca, man kommt um dieses Thema nicht herum. Da geht es jetzt dann weiter. Die spielen gegen Levante am 26. Die andere Partie habe ich jetzt gerade noch nicht rausgefunden. Nee, es durfte schon die nächste von Barca sein. Die haben ja erst gestern gespielt. Ach ja, es rattert gerade so durch in La Liga. Zwei Fragen habe ich noch abschließend an dich. Zum einen gibt es noch irgendeine Mannschaft, die unten drin hängt, wo du sagst, oh, das ist jetzt eher überraschend. Und zweitens haben sich die Hörerinnen und Hörer nach der letzten Ausgabe der Ligatur gewünscht, dass die Experten immer einen Tipp abgeben, wen sollte man denn angucken? Bei wem ist immer was los in den Spielen? Das würde mich jetzt mal noch für La Liga interessieren.
Also immer abwarten, was noch bei Espanol Barcelona passiert. Für mich eigentlich auch eher eins der schlechteren Teams. Ich denke, Celta, Vigo hat genug Potenzial, um weiter umzustehen. Auch der FC Granada, der ja eigentlich die letzten Jahre richtig gut gearbeitet hat, auch in der Europa League war, wo er glaube ich auch dieses Jahr wieder ist. Und die haben mit Robert Moreno den ehemaligen Nationaltrainer Spaniens, der auch bei Monaco war. Also ich denke, da wird auf jeden Fall noch was nach oben gehen. Elche ist ganz interessant. Da ist, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht ganz täusche, ein argentinischer, reicher Geldgeber eingestiegen. Die haben die letzten Jahre das Team deutlich verstärkt. Jetzt ist ja auch Javier Pastore von der Serie A dahin gewechselt.
Aber das ist noch nicht dein Spektakeltipp, oder? Weil die haben eine Vorteferenz von drei zu drei nach fünf Jahren.
Das ist noch nicht der Spektakeltipp. Das sind nur die Teams, die man noch ein bisschen im Auge haben sollte. Nein, ein Spektakel, denke ich, auf jeden Fall. Mir gefällt ziemlich gut Valencia dieses Jahr. Die haben mit Bordolas einen Trainer, der jetzt menschlich nicht der beliebteste ist, aber der aus seinen Teams dafür bekannt ist, immer das krasseste Meister rauszuhöhlen, spielt oft an der Grenze zum Feiern. Aber ich denke, Valencia kann dieses Jahr vorne mit dabei sein. Und die haben vom Einsatz und von der Leidenschaft her einen ziemlich hohen Faktor. Und ansonsten die bereits erwähnten Reihe Valcano, finde ich sehr interessant. Und Real Sociedad San Sebastian, spielt in den letzten Jahren einen sehr erfrischenden Offensivfußball.
Okay, dann wisst ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wo ihr mal reingucken könnt in der spanischen Liga. Jetzt wollen wir kommen zur Ligue 1 mit David von 93. David, wir haben ja schon in der ersten Ligatur miteinander gesprochen. Da hatten wir so einige Dinge aufzuarbeiten. Unter anderem einen Messi-Wechsel. Wir hatten aber auch Ausschreitungen bei Niza gegen Marseille. Auch darum soll es ja heute mal gehen. Was ist so passiert in den letzten Wochen in der Liga?
Schon wieder Ausschreitungen. Frankreich kommt nicht aus den Schlagzeilen heraus, aufseits des Platzes. Beim Derby du Nord, beim Derby zwischen Lens und Lidl, gab es einen Platzsturm. Das sind zwei Nachbarstädte. Lens ist vergleichsweise klein. Ich glaube, die haben weniger als 50.000 Einwohner. Aber glorreiche Fußballvergangheit, vor allem in den 90ern, spielen in diesen wunderschönen Farben rot und gelb, oder wie sie selbst sagen, Blut und Gold. Und Lidl immerhin 10 größer Stadt Frankreichs.
Klingt nach Game of Thrones, ehrlich gesagt eher als Fußball.
Genau, also Nachbarstädte, Derby, großes Getümmel. Und die Fans von Lidl und Lons waren durch ein Gitter getrennt. Dann sind in der Halbzeitpause Gegenstände geflogen, inklusive Sitze. Dann sind Lons Anhänger in der Halbzeitpause auf dem Platz gestürmt, um das Gitter zu umgehen. Sicherheitskräfte kamen, dann sind weitere Fans runter. Bilanz am Ende, sechs Verletzte. Einer hätte beinahe sein Auge verloren, hab ich gelesen. Das war alles nicht sehr schön. Wobei offenbar auch Verletzte durch das Eingreifen der Sicherheitskräfte. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, selbst... Also, es war insgesamt alles sehr unschön. Darauf können wir uns einigen. Und die Spieler haben von den Alden nichts mitbekommen, im Gegensatz damals zu Nitsa Massey, wo ja teilweise Spieler angegriffen wurden, verwickelt waren, wo ja ein Massey-Coach sogar einen Fan angegriffen hat. Das war diesmal nicht der Fall. Die Halbzeitpause hat 45 Minuten gedauert. Das alles ist insofern ärgerlich, weil es abermals, ähnlich schon wie bei Nitsa gegen Massey, ein spannendes Ergebnis bis in den Hintergrund hat rücken lassen. Denn L'Anse hat gewonnen, ja immerhin gegen den Meister Lil, nachdem sie da in der Vorsaison zweimal richtig abgewatscht worden sind. Und L'Anse setzt damit einen absolut fantastischen Saisonstart vor. Die sind schon vergangenen Saison als Aufsteiger knapp an der Europa League vorbei geschrammt und stehen aktuell auf Platz zwei hinter Paris. Wobei man sagen muss, Marseille und Nizza haben aktuell noch ein Spiel weniger. Da kann ich gleich noch was zu sagen zu dem Fallout dieser Sache, die wir letztes Mal angesprochen haben. Aber L'Anse vielleicht noch ganz kurz, sammelt ehemalige Bundesligaspieler, also dann so von ehemals Augsburg, ist da in der Abwehr ganz gut rührig. Hat übrigens witzigerweise über die Stimmung in L'Anse gesagt, also abgesehen von Dortmund und Köln, habe ich nirgendwo eine so tolle Stimmung erlebt wie im Bolleier.
Aber das hat er zu französischen Medien gesagt.
Das hat er zu französischen Medien gesagt, ja. Gut.
Er hat ja trotzdem Stimmen. Ich wollte es nur kurz einordnen.
Ähm, nee, also tatsächlich, die L'Anse-Fans sind schon bekannt für gute Stimmung. Das ist schon so. Und Klaus, der hat zwei Jahre in Bielefeld gespielt, der war schon vergangene Saison sehr, sehr stark. Da habe ich schon Hinweise bekommen, auch von Bielefeld-Fans hier anscheinend sehr vermissen.
Und haben die einen besonderen Spielstil, der sie auszeichnet, wenn sie das jetzt schaffen, schon im zweiten Jahr nacheinander eine so gute Saison zu spielen? Und letzte Spielzeit hat es ja dann nur knapp nicht geklappt und hatte ja auch damit zu tun, dass viele andere, also da hatten wir ja ein Titelrennen, und dementsprechend war es alles ein bisschen enger oben an der Spitze.
Ja, mannschaftliche Geschlossenheit, würde ich erst mal sagen. Da ich gerade schon erwähnt habe, das sind jetzt alles keine herausragenden Spieler. Du hast einen Vorfahrener, der kurz bei City hätte gewesen sein sollen, aber dann hier wirklich zum Zug kam, der auch schon letztes Jahr dahin gewechselt ist, der dann auch gefragt wurde, wieso wechselst du zu einem Aufsteiger? Und er sagt hat, ja, aber Stimmung und so weiter, und geschlossenheitlich glaube ich, die kommen ganz, ganz stark über das Team. Nach wie vor bin ich auch gespannt, wie weit die sich da halten können. Aber auch das haben wir letztes Mal schon gesprochen, diverse größere Mannschaften schwächeln. Lilo habe ich gerade erwähnt, Monaco geht das auch weiterhin nicht gut. Die Medien schreiben, Nübel sei ein Klotz am Bein der monägarischen Abwehr. Der Nübel präsentiert sich so dermaßen schlecht, dass die Abwehrspieler sich nicht trauen, nach vorne zu laufen und so. Da gibt es, ähnlich wie auch in der Bundesliga, immer wieder mal diverse große Namen, die aktuell straucheln. Und da kann eben ein Team, das geschlossen auftritt, das einen gewissen Plan hat, da einfach auch die Früchte ernten.
Okay, also Nübel ist jetzt inzwischen ein Klotz. Das habe ich schon mitgenommen. Wenn wir dann sowieso schon dabei sind, noch ein kurzes Wort zu Lille. Die ihren Meister-Trainer auch verloren haben, haben wir ja auch letzte Woche schon angesprochen, die immer noch nicht da unten rausgekommen sind. Jetzt nach sechs Spielen erst einen Sieg, zwei Unentschieden, drei Niederlagen aktuell, Tabellenplatz 15 und schon 13 Schmuckepunkte Rückstand auf die Tabellenspitze. Selbst wenn das jetzt vielleicht nicht der eigentliche Maßstab ist. Aber das sieht so aus, als hätte sich da wenig zum Positiven getan.
Ja, die hatten zwischendrin ein Hoch, wo man wieder gedacht hatte, jetzt sieht man das wahre Lil. Es ist ein bisschen schwer zu greifen. Es liegt sicherlich auch am Trainerwechsel, würde ich sagen. Meistertrainer Galtier ist ja zu Nizza rüber. Ich habe nach wie vor Schwierigkeiten. Vielleicht kann man auch sagen, dass sie einfach mit der Mannschaft ein klein bisschen überperformt haben vergangener Saison. Es sind ja auch einige ältere Spieler mit drin. Aber da passt einiges nicht so richtig zusammen. Okay.
Ja gut, so ist es ja manchmal, dass man das auch gar nicht so klar in Worte fassen kann, wie sportliche Miseren dann zustande kommen. Aber du hast ja schon die perfekte Überleitung gebaut, indem du Nizza kurz angesprochen hast. Was kam denn jetzt da eigentlich bei raus, bei dem Spiel, über das wir das letzte Mal so lange geredet haben, Nizza gegen Olympique Marseille, das ja dann abgebrochen wurde?
Genau. Zur Erinnerung, die Liga hätte sich ja entscheiden können, die Punkte am grünen Tisch an Marseille zu geben, weil das ja eben zum Platzsturm kam und zu Angriffen von Fans. Sie hätte die Punkte auch Nizza geben können, weil das Spiel ja offiziell wieder angepfiffen wurde am Ende und Marseille dann nicht erschienen ist. Wobei sie ja zurücklagen eben. Das ist ja auch eine Art von Präzedenzfall dann. Ein Team soll wieder antreten, erscheint aber nicht. Sie haben ganz vor allem getan, sie haben sich vor der Entscheidung gedrückt und haben das Spiel jetzt wiederholen lassen. Oder werden das Spiel wiederholen lassen, das kommt jetzt noch. Nizza bekommt allerdings einen Punkt Abzug direkt, einen zweiten auf Bewährung. Das heißt, am Ende könnte es jetzt sein, wenn Nizza verliert, dann sind sie durchaus heftig bestraft mit vier bis fünf Punkten weniger, die sie ansonsten gehabt hätten. Wenn Nizza gewinnt, sind sie vergleichsweise glimpflich davongekommen. Drei Spiele, Stadion... Na, Stadionsperle wollte ich gerade sagen, nein. Geisterspiele? Geisterspiele, genau, Entschuldigung. Drei Spiele Geisterspiele auch nur, das ist auch vergleichsweise wenig. Also, die Liga wurde durchaus dafür kritisiert, dass sie in vielerlei Hinsicht sehr, sehr wenig Entscheidungen getroffen hat. Auch was die Person nicht strafen für die Spieler angeht. Der Einzige, der wirklich hart bestraft wurde, ist der Co-Trainer von Samparoli, der da den Nizza-Fan angegriffen hat. Der darf bis auf Weiteres nicht mehr Co-Trainer sein. Aber wenn die ein aufeinander stoßen, das könnte ein großartiges Spiel werden. War es ja eigentlich in der ersten Variante schon. Weil beide Mannschaften sind nach wie vor in absolut großartiger Form. Also Nizza ist eine Freude, jede Woche zuzusehen. Du hast ja schon gesagt, die Rasenfunkerer haben ja gefragt nach Fernsehtipps. Ich hätte gerne Nizza empfohlen. Ich hab in weiser Voraussicht schon mal geschaut, was sie denn überhaupt übertragen hier in Deutschland. Und Nizza wird nicht übertragen in nächster Zeit. Also kann ich es nicht empfehlen. Und dann empfehle ich stattdessen Marseille. Die spielen nämlich am 22., also am Mittwoch, englische Woche auch wir in Frankreich gegen Angers, ebenfalls derzeit extrem stark. Und am Sonntag, den 26., gegen Lens. Ach, guck an. Beide Spiele so gegen 21 Uhr.
Wenn es da nicht um Blut und Gold geht, dann würde ich auch nicht weiter.
Genau. Marseille mit ebenfalls einem alten Bekannten, Guendouzi, eben als Hertha, der mit seinem Temperament hier sehr gut aufgenommen wurde bei den Marseille-Fans, aber tatsächlich auch sehr stark spielt. Mit starken neuen Außenspielern. De La Fuente auf links und Cengiz Hünder auf rechts. De La Fuente kam von Barcelona B. Und so wie der aktuell spielt, hätte ich den nicht abgegeben. Also, der ist ein Amerikaner anscheinend. Was heißt anscheinend? Nein, er ist Amerikaner, Punkt. Also, starke Transfers in der Sommerpause. Und da scheint einiges sehr, sehr gut zu klicken. Und die Fans, die südamerikanischen, die südfranzösischen Fans, Marseille hat ja auch einen Ruf, einfach als emotionaler Verein. Die sind sehr, sehr versöhnt gerade mit ihrer Mannschaft. Da passt sehr viel einfach zusammen gerade gut.
Und es sieht ja so ein bisschen aus, von der jetzigen Tabellenkonstellation aus, dass sollte Marseille dieses Spiel gegen Nizza gewinnen, dann könnte man bis auf zwei Punkte an PSG heranrücken. PSG bisher makellose Bilanz, sechs Spiele, sechs Siege. Das heißt, wenn es einen Meisterschaftskampf gäbe, dann wäre ja wahrscheinlich Marseille eine derjenigen Mannschaften, die dafür sorgen könnte, oder?
Genau, das ist sicherlich auch die Hoffnung in Frankreich. Ich meine, Marseille nach wie vor der große Club. Ja, also würde sicherlich Spaß machen, würde sicherlich noch für mehr Feuer sorgen in der Liga, wenn da tatsächlich Marseille mal wieder Paris rausfordern könnte.
Tja, aber da hat ja auch Paris mit zu tun. Die haben nicht nur ihre sechs Siege in der Liga eingefahren, sondern sie sind jetzt auch in der Champions League gestartet. Und das unter den Erwartungen, die aber naturgemäß auch sehr hoch sind, bei Brügge nur eins zu eins gespielt. Ich habe jetzt auch gelesen, dass Lionel Messi ausgewechselt wurde, wurde er nicht sogar für Telukera ausgewechselt?
Gegen Lionel dann, ja, genau.
Genau, das war dann quasi... Fabian hat sich schon entmuted und will uns, glaube ich, was sagen, wie Messi das so findet, wenn er ausgewechselt wird.
Das haben wir letztes Mal schon besprochen. Da haben wir bereits so reingegangen, dass er das überhaupt nicht gut findet.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen die Crux, finde ich, bei Teams mit Messi. Das ist das, was ich vorher auch angesprochen habe. Über die individuelle Klasse von Messi müssen wir uns alle, glaube ich, gar nicht unterhalten. Das haben wir schon öfter mal erleben dürfen. Aber was das Teamgefüge anbelangt, was das Mannschaftsspiel anbelangt, ist es halt nicht so optimal. Also, ich meine, bei Barcelona war das Spiel der letzten Jahre darauf ausgelegt, ihm den Ball zu geben im vorderen Drittel. Und dann schauen wir ihm mal zu, was er macht. Und ich habe auch so das Gefühl, dass er bei Paris so ein ähnliches Problem darstellen könnte, dass er einfach andere Spieler tapiert, sagt man in Spanien. Also, dass er halt deren Präsenz ein bisschen wegnimmt. Und ich habe auch ein paar Ausschnitte gesehen, zwar von spanischen Medien, deswegen kann ich das jetzt nicht 100% bestätigen, das kannst du vielleicht sagen, David, wo halt auch Spieler um die Ruhm standen und ihn alle angeschaut haben, weil keiner wusste, gibt er jetzt den Ball ab, oder dribbelt er, oder was macht er? Also da hat Pochettino zwar einen tollen Spieler jetzt geholt bzw. bekommen, aber der hat auch eine richtig große Aufgabe jetzt da, ein harmonisches Team daraus zu bilden.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also um das nochmal kurz aufzudröseln, die Sache, die du gerade angesprochen hast, Max, die Story war, dass er gegen Lyon, ich muss jetzt nochmal nachschauen, es war die 70., 75. Minute, wo er ausgewechselt, Quatsch, also es wurde Hakimi eingewechselt. Hakimi war nicht von Anfang auf auf dem Platz. Keira war für ihn auf dem Platz. Und jeder hat damit gerechnet, dass natürlich jetzt Hakimi reinkommt, Keira rausgeht. Was da passiert ist, ist, dass Messis Nummer aufblitzte und Messi für Hakimi rausging und dann Hakimi auf der Messi-Position spielte und Keira drin blieb. Das war diese Story.
Gut, das hat nicht an ihm vorbeigekommen. Er liegt ja auch im teaminternen Torschützen-Ranking hinter Julian Draxler, der schon ein Tor gemacht hat.
Keira und Draxler haben einen starken Saisonstart. Es haben einige Spieler aus der BRB-Elf von Paris einen starken Saisonstart hingelegt. Insgesamt, ich glaube, Pochettino hat bislang 27 verschiedene Spieler eingesetzt. Er ist in allen sechs Spielen mit einer anderen Formation aufgelaufen. Wenn natürlich die Spieler nicht so ganz auf Messi eingehen können oder nicht ganz so wissen, ob er jetzt abspielt und was er tut, dann liegt das sicherlich auch schlichtweg daran, dass er mit ihnen erst ein, zwei Spiele gemacht hat. Diese ganze Mannschaft muss sich auf jeden Fall noch finden. Diese Auswechslung hat er sehr unwirrisch quittiert. Auf den Fernsehbildern sah es aus, als hätte er den Handschlag verweigert. Er saß dann sehr, sehr mürrisch auf der Bank drauf. Pochettino sagt jetzt, er hatte vorher einen Schlag abbekommen, wollte nichts riskieren. Was man halt auch so sagt. Anscheinend ist er am nächsten Tag beim Training. Er hatte dann Dessouren, ist nicht zum Training erschienen. Lequip titelt heute Morgen A Soft Power auf der Titelseite mit Pochettino drauf. Es stellt die Frage, ob er autoritär oder eher weniger autoritär umgehen soll mit dieser Mannschaft.
Das ist alles fürchterlich, ey. Das ist, wenn Fußball zu Daily Soap-Berichterstattung wird. Vielleicht bin ich da auch ein bisschen humorlos, aber das ist ja fürchterlich. Das interessiert doch keinen. Dann soll er halt mürrisch sein, weil er ausgewechselt ist. Ja, meine Güte, ihr werdet euch schon alle finden.
Also, boah. Auf dem Platz haben wir tatsächlich ein Problem, weil du hast angesprochen, gegen Brügge war das Mausch. Da stand ja erstmals der Supersturm auf dem Platz. Und die Pässe gezählt zwischen Messi und Mbappé, es kam auf drei Pässe. Und zwischen Mbappé und Neymar kam es auf fünf Pässe. Das war nicht gut. Und die starken Spieler in dem Spiel waren andere. Das war Herrera vor allem, der eine absolut überragend grandiose Saison bislang spielt. Der nicht der technisch stärkste ist in dieser Mannschaft, der nicht der talentierteste ist, aber der anscheinend derjenige ist, der gerade Mitspieler im Blick hat und sich für andere Mitspieler reinhaut und für sie läuft und Laufwege abschätzen kann und Pässe spielt, was die anderen teilweise nicht machen. Das ist jetzt alles auch nicht überraschend. Das haben wir natürlich auch im Vorfeld alle vermutet. Was machst du, wenn du drei der besten Spieler der Welt da vorne versammelst? Kann das gut gehen? Aktuelle Antwort, hm, noch nicht. Weil wenn Neymar von deinen drei Offensivkräften derjenige ist, der das größte Lob in der Rückwärtsverteidigung bekommt, dann hast du möglicherweise ein Problem.
Aber wir sind schon leicht über der Zeit. Und ich hab so das Gefühl, dass wir noch häufiger über PSG sprechen werden. Ich weiß nicht, woher dieses Gefühl kommt. Aber lass noch ganz kurz ein Wort zu Peter Boss verlieren. Da haben wir letzte Woche, bzw. in der letzten Ausgabe, schon drüber gesprochen, und Lyon hatte ja dieses Spiel gegen PSG mit der Messi-Auswechslung, dass PSG auch erst in der Nachspielzeit mit 2 zu 1 für sich entscheiden konnte.
Genau, und man muss sogar sagen, Lyon hätte den Sieg verdient gehabt. Paris hatte einen sehr strittigen Elfmeter, da hat sich Neymar eingehakt und ist dann gefallen. Das hätte man nicht pfeifen müssen. Am Ende kommt so ein Lucky Punch durch Icardi, der als Joker reinkam und keinen Ballkontakt hatte. Wir haben über Bosz gespürtelt, das stimmt. Und seit drei Spieltagen hat Lyon eine deutlich aufsteigende Kurve. Das sah sehr ansprechend aus.
Wir haben dafür verantwortlich, das sagst du damit, oder?
Wir haben es gejinkst. Die haben noch mal überraschend stark nachgelegt mit Shakiri und Boateng. Und das scheint dieser sehr jungen Lyon-Mannschaft sehr kurz zu tun. Vor allem Shakiri hat direkt mal sehr schön Harmonie gezeigt, gute Positionierung, sich zwischen die Verteidigungslinien gemogelt. Das sah alles ganz gut aus. Und offenbar scheint das Team die Philosophie von Bosch aktuell besser zu verinnerlichen. Wir schauen mal, wie es weitergeht.
Das könnte ja dann auch dein spektakulärer Tipp sein, denn wir wissen, bei Boss-Teams passiert immer viel. Wer ist denn die Mannschaft, die man so verfolgen sollte?
Hab ich doch gesagt, Marseille.
Ach so, Entschuldigung.
Ich hab den Fernsehtipp schon gesagt. Morgen gegen Troyes und dann am Samstag gegen Lorient.
Gut. Aber Marseille war eigentlich der Tipp. Das hab ich ja jetzt sehr mitentschuldigt. Jetzt bin ich gespannt, wie ich durch das Segment der Serie A komme, über die wir jetzt zum ersten Mal sprechen in dieser Saison. Vier Spieltage sind da bisher gespielt. Christian Bernhard ist mit dabei. Vertraute Stimme aus dem Rasenfunk. Freue mich sehr, dass du mal wieder Zeit hast. Tja, womit wollen wir anfangen? Allein, wenn ich mir die Tabelle angucke, habe ich gesagt, das wird jetzt mit einer Viertelstunde sportlich. Womit würdest du gerne beginnen? Willst du oben anfangen, willst du unten anfangen?
Du hast überall große Namen, suchst dir auch.
Dann lass doch mal mit dem großen Namen unten anfangen. Natürlich meine ich damit Salernitana völlig überraschend auf Platz 20. Ich spreche natürlich von Juve auf Platz 18. Noch kein Sieg, zwei Unentschieden, zwei Niederlagen. Damit ist logischerweise erst zwei Punkte geholt, womit man jetzt schon nach vier Spielen schmucke 10 Punkte Rückstand auf Napoli auf Tabellenplatz 1 hat. Was ist da denn los?
Vieles ist los. Wo fangen wir an? Allegri ist im Sommer sehr zurückgekommen, nach dem Mann, der Juve damals zu vielen Skudette geführt hat. Irgendwie ist da eine Mannschaft, die sich überhaupt noch nicht gefunden hat. Jetzt gab es zuletzt die zwei Spitzenspiele am Wochenende gegen Milan 1-1, zuvor gegen Napoli, was sie 1-2 verloren haben. Das würde ich mal in Klammern setzen, weil da haben sie ohne die Südamerikaner gespielt, die gerade von der Koalit zurückgekommen sind am selben Tag. Da haben sechs oder sieben Stammspieler gefehlt. Das würde ich mal in Klammern setzen, aber es ist ein Trend, der sich abzeichnet. Die Juve war schon mehrfach in Führung, hat es dann nie über die Runden gebracht. Und eine Statistik, die wirklich, ich finde, hin und wieder gibt es Statistiken, die bleiben einem hängen. Und ich finde, das ist so eine. Juve kassiert mittlerweile seit 18 Liga-Spielen saisonübergreifend mindestens ein Gegentor. Das ist nicht das, was man, glaube ich, allgemein viele Menschen von Juve in Erinnerungen haben. Und jetzt kommt noch krassere Teil meiner Meinung nach. Es gibt in den Top-5-Ligen Europas keine Mannschaft, die so lange in Serie Gegentoren kassiert. Also diese Defensivstabilität, diese Konzentrationsfähigkeit. Gestern gegen Milan waren sie 1-0 vorne. Dann dachtest du dir vielleicht, ja, das alte Juve verteidigt das dann einfach zu Ende und nimmt den Dreier mit. Aber nein, dann kassieren sie wieder in Gegentoren nach Standard. Also es ist eine riesige, offene Paustelle. Allegri muss ich auch erst wieder finden. Macht einen unglücklichen Eindruck für mich bisher. Ja, und du hast es angesprochen, schwupp, sind vier Spieltage vorbei und du bist zehn Punkte hinten. Das macht den Druck jetzt auch nicht unbedingt kleiner.
Das kann ich mir allerdings vorstellen. Man hat immerhin in der Champions League gewinnen können gegen Malmö 3 zu 0. Das war ja dann, wenn man so möchte, der erste Sieg. Beziehungsweise gegen Atalanta gab es noch einen, bevor die Serie A dann gestartet ist. Ich nehme an, das wird alles zurückhaltend aufgenommen und in wenig großen Headlines berichtet in der italienischen Presse. Es gäbe aber auch noch viele andere Themen. Du hast es angesprochen, unter anderem Napoli, die bisher mit vier Siegen aus vier Spielen durch diese Saison durchgegangen sind. Du hast ja auch gerade den Sieg gegen Juve eingeordnet. Kann man sich da erhoffen, dass es dieses Jahr vielleicht mal richtig interessant wird in der Serie A?
Die Hoffnung habe ich auf jeden Fall. Das war ja, glaube ich, auch die letzten ein, zwei Jahre. Letztes Jahr hat Inter dann den großen Schritt gemacht. Aber ich glaube, dieses Jahr könnte es so eng wie lange nicht mehr werden, wenn du hast wirklich die sieben großen, in Italien sagt man le sette sorelle, also die sieben Schwestern, die es früher mal gab, also die zwei Römer, die zwei Meiländer, Napoli, Juve und Atalanta, die wirklich noch enger zusammengerückt sind, meiner Meinung nach. Inter kommen danach noch kurz, hat Lukaku, Konte und Hakimi verloren, macht trotzdem einen guten Eindruck. Die anderen sind näher rangekommen. Also ich glaube, wir können uns da auf ein enges Ding einstellen. Und Napoli macht wirklich nicht nur wegen den vier Siegen großen Spaß. Also da ist ja auch Spalletti zurückgekommen. Was heißt zurückgekommen?
Also zurück in die Liga.
Ganz interessant, er war so wie der Lege! Die waren beide zwei Jahre raus, komplett raus. Aber Spalletti hat deutlich weniger Anpassungsschwierigkeiten. Also da scheint sich die Stadt Neapel und Spalletti, das scheint sehr gut zu passen. Auch der Verein hat sehr viel Enthusiasmus mitgebracht. Er hat ja auch Erfahrungen mit nicht einfachen Orten. Bei der Roma mit Totti und Rossi, dass er das so managen musste, war bei Inter auch schon als ein erfahrener Mann. Napoli spielt wirklich einen entzückenden Offensivfußball. War auch in der Europa League gegen Leicester zuletzt unter der Woche wirklich ein sehr, sehr, sehr gutes Spiel. Waren 0-2, in Leicester zurück, haben noch zum 2-2 ausgeglichen. Victor Ossimen da vorne ist eine Naturgewalt. Was die sonst an Offensivpotenzial mit Insigne, Lozano, Politano, Mertens ist noch gar nicht fit. Da ist noch einiges in der Hinterhand. Und wirklich herausragend, Napoli hat nach vier Spieltagen neun unterschiedliche Torschützen. Das zeigt dann auch, dass die Mannschaft wirklich viele Varianten hat, auch ihre Offensivstärke mit einzubringen. Spalletti hat da im Moment die Mischung, passt wunderbar.
Hat sich denn da was beim Spielstil verändert? Napoli gehört ja zu den Mannschaften, die immer wieder ähnlich spielen. Zumindest gespielt haben in den letzten Jahren, meine ich jetzt. Ist das jetzt quasi eine Weiterentwicklung? Hat Spalletti da neue Elemente mit reingebracht?
Ich finde, Napoli hat letzte Saison auch noch unter Gattuso immer wieder mal gezeigt, was sie offensiv können. Weitere Entwicklungen ist ein guter Punkt. Sie haben brutales Offensivpotenzial. Wie gesagt, ich habe ja ein paar schon aufgezählt. Wie die auch auf offensiven Außen besetzt sind. Da ist auch Tiefe drin. Da wird schnell direkt gespielt. Da sind viele Abläufe schon drin. Und die große Frage war ja immer, wie du das dann halt defensiv compensierst. Und da ist zum Beispiel der Sessionsstart von Colibaly herausragend. Er hat gestern wieder getroffen und ist jetzt mit zwei Toren auch der beste Torschütze der Mannschaft. Aber er räumt halt hinten brutal auf. Das war ja auch so ein Fragezeichen. Wieder im Sommer bleibt er, geht er. Aber Gott sei Dank aus Napolis Sicht ist er geblieben. Und ein extremer Stabilisator, wirklich auch ein Anführer. Er und Insigne sind da wirklich die ganz klaren Vorangeher. Fabian Ruiz hat einen sehr guten Start im Mittelfeld gehabt, der ja auch wichtig ist für die Balance dieses Teams. Also es scheint eine sehr gute Mischung zu sein. Und wie gesagt, die Offensivbau, die war die letzten Jahre schon da und die kommt jetzt irgendwie noch besser kontrollierter auf dem Rasen im Moment.
Das klingt doch ganz fantastisch. Und ähnlich gut sieht es ja gerade bei Inter aus, obwohl du hast es ja schon angesprochen, damit jetzt gar nicht so zu rechnen war. Man hat Romelu Lukaku verloren, man hat Achaf Hakimi verloren, unter anderem, natürlich wurden die auch ersetzt, aber wir alle wissen ja um die Qualität von ihnen. Wie hat sich denn Inter weiterentwickelt? Oder in welche Richtung hat sich Inter entwickelt?
Ja, ich muss auch sagen, ich bin positiv überrascht von Inter. Wir haben es angesprochen, Lukaku weg, Hakimi weg, Konte weg, der Mann, der Inter wieder den Skudetter gebracht hat. Und wenn man jetzt auch noch Herrn Christian Eriksen nennt, der aus anderen Gründen nicht dabei ist, dann ist das, also ich kann mich nicht erinnern in den letzten Jahren, dass eine europäische Top-Mannschaft oder ein amtierender Meister in einem Sommer so viel Qualität verloren hat. Aber sie haben es brutal gut aufgefangen. Simone Insage, der neue Trainer, der von Lazio gekommen ist, ist wirklich gut reingekommen, hat eine gute Ansprache gefunden, sehr gutes Gefühl schon für die Mannschaft entwickelt. Lukaku wurde im Prinzip doppelt abgefangen oder versucht, doppelt anzufangen. Es kamen Dzeko von der Roma und Correa von Lazio, also zwei Stürmer, die ihn so ein bisschen auffangen sollten. Auch das klappt wunderbar.
Dzeko hat sich schon perfekt da eingefügt.
Das ist logischerweise ein ganz anderer Stürmer-Tipp als Lukaku, aber einer, der wahnsinnig viel mitspielt. Da hat sich Inter jetzt zumindest in der ersten Saisonphase weiterentwickelt. Insagi hat durchaus nicht mehr dieses tiefstehende Konterfußball, um dann die Tiefe mit Lukaku zu attackieren, sondern da wird auch Dzeko als Offensivregisseur mit eingebunden. Da fühlt sich Lautaro sehr wohl, Martinez neben Dzeko, weil er mit dem auch auf engen Raum gut kombinieren kann. Corea hat sich gleich super eingefügt mit einem entscheidenden Doppelpack. Und auf rechts eben, für Hakimi wurde Denzel Dumfries geholt, von Isländer, der ja bei der EM für ziemlich Alarm gesorgt hat. Und den hat Insagi jetzt ganz langsam mit eingebaut, hat ihn meistens in den ersten Spielen von der Bank gebracht. Während der Woche hat er ihn das erste Mal losgelassen. Und von Anfang an, da hat er einfach mal kurz Bologna kaputt gespielt. Ich glaube, von den sechs Hintertoren sind vier oder fünf über seine Seite vorbereitet worden. Also ich glaube, Dumfries hat zumindest offensiv durchaus das Potenzial, da in die sehr, sehr großen Fußstapfen von Hakimi annähernd zu treten.
6 zu 1 ging das Spiel gegen Bologna aus. Inter deswegen mit drei Siegen, einem Unentschieden. Aktuell 10 Punkten und einer sehr schönen Torbilanz von 15 zu 4 Toren. Da kommen eben jetzt sechs, kamen da jetzt eben Jungs noch mit dazu. Das liegt man ganz gut da. Und wenn wir bei Umbruch sind, das wäre überhaupt nur eine Frage, ob das irgendwie auch gerade, warum das gerade so ein roter Faden ist, dass viele Mannschaften im Umbruch sind, dann denke ich, sollten wir auch über den AC, also Milan, mal sprechen. Die sehen von der Bilanz her, sieht das wunderbar aus. Erst zwei Gegentreffer kassiert, ebenso drei Siege, ein Unentschieden. Aber da hat sich ja auch so einiges getan. Donnerruma ja unter anderem weg, Cialanolo weg. Wie hat Milan es geschafft, das alles aufzufangen? Auch die ganze Unruhe, die es da ja zusätzlich noch gab. Ich fand, die war ja bis nach Deutschland zu hören.
Ja, aber ich finde, das haben sie schon letzte Saison wunderbar moderiert. Also auch diese ganze Donnerruma-Geschichte mit Rayola. Man erinnert sich vielleicht noch. Rayola hat weiter gebogen, wollte dann irgendwann 10 Millionen und was auch immer. Und irgendwann hat Milan ganz einfach gesagt, ja, nee, dann macht es ohne uns. Und haben Mike Manon verpflichtet von Lille. Und damit war dann auch, also das ging von Milan auch aus. Sie haben irgendwann verstanden, dass sie dann nicht mehr zueinander kommen zu diesen Preisen, dass sie nicht gewollt waren, zu zahlen. Und deswegen, fand ich, haben sie das auch gut moderiert, auch mit Ciano Noglo. Okay, dann geht er eben zu Inter ablösefrei. Das war jetzt sicherlich nicht im Interesse von Milan. Aber Brahim Dias, der ja wieder von Real ausgeliehen wurde, fühlt diese Rolle von Ciano Noglo bisher sehr, sehr gut aus, hat letztes Jahr schon gute Ansätze gehabt, übernimmt jetzt im Prinzip diese 10er-Rolle, macht das sehr, sehr gut. Sandro Tonali, das große italienische Talent, das letztes Jahr seine erste Saison bei Milan hatte, da ein bisschen Probleme hatte mit dem Druck, große Aufmerksamkeit, ist jetzt auch übern Sommer ein ganz anderer Spieler geworden. Viel mehr Selbstsicherheit, viel von diesen Qualitäten, die er in seinen begehrtesten Talente Europas gemacht hat, sind jetzt da, hat viel mehr Selbstvertrauen, ist jetzt der Mann für die Standards, hat auch Ciano Noglo weggegeben, es hat ihm nochmal auch Sicherheit gegeben. Milan für mich eine wahnsinnig spannende Mannschaft, denn wenn man mal Ibrahimović und Kier weglassen, dann ist das eine Mannschaft, die immer noch unfassbar jung ist, mit vielen Potenzialen nach oben. Du kannst da anfangen, hinten Theo Hernandez, Calabria, Tomori, Cassier, Tonali, Benazer, Léo. Also die Liste ist fast endlos lang. Das sind Spieler, die immer noch viel Luft nach oben haben und die sich unter Piolli in der letzten Saison schon sehr gut entwickelt haben. Und die jetzt, glaube ich, gerade so zum Beispiel Léo und Tonali scheinen, dass die nochmal den nächsten Schritt machen. Also für mich ist Milan ein ganz heißer Kandidat für einen Titel.
Und bei Brahim Dias, muss ich ganz kurz rein grätschen, wenn ich darf, der kommt nämlich aus Malara, aus der Stadt, in der ich lebe. Und galt hier als Jahrhunderttalent, wurde dann zuerst, glaube ich, zu Manchester City verkauft, da wollte Guardiola ihn fördern, das hat nicht so ganz geklappt. Und dann bei Real Madrid auch nicht so. Aber ich glaube, bei Milan startet er diese Saison, oder auch letzte schon, richtig durch, oder?
Ja, absolut. Da fühlt sich da, wie gesagt, die Saison war letztes Jahr schon immer wieder gut, aber da war er dann doch ein bisschen im Schatten von Cialanoglu. Und jetzt ist er die klare 10, nicht nur auf dem Rücken, sondern hat auch das Vertrauen von Piolli da voll, dieser Mann auf dieser Position zu sein. Wahnsinnig dribbelt stark, auf engem Raum findet er Lösungen, gute Entscheidungsfindung. Also, ne, das ist einer dieser Spieler, der so sinnbildlich für Milan steht, ein junger Spieler, der noch Potenzial nach oben hat, und der schon im Kollektiv mit dieser Mannschaft gute Schritte in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren mit Piolli gegangen ist. Und da geht es für mich eindeutig weiter nach oben.
Und ich setze zweite Grätsche hinterher, also Menyon tatsächlich auch eine Schwächung für Lille, weil du es ja auch gerade hattest von Meistermannschaften, die geschwächt werden und durchweg gingen. Und weil wir es eben auch gerade noch von Lille hatten, die durchaus schwächelten.
Sehr gute Ergänzung. Danke dir, David. Und wenn du dich verabschieden musst, dann leg gerne einfach auf. Du hast doch auch einen Anflusstermin.
I sense a pattern hier, ich muss schon wieder früher raus. Dabei haben wir uns extra diesmal die Zeit genommen. Aber ich werde schon wieder das letzte Segment nicht hören. Wir schaffen das irgendwann.
Wir müssen einfach nur alle ganz fest dran glauben und uns an den Händen halten. David, danke dir für deine Zeit. Viel Spaß zum nächsten Termin. Ja, Christian, wir wollen noch weiter über die Serie A sprechen. Gefühlt hätten wir noch 1.000 Themen. Das ist auch das Problem, wenn wir jetzt zum ersten Mal über diese Liga sprechen. Was würdest du denn jetzt noch hervorheben wollen?
Ich würde die Roma hervorheben wollen. Die große Frage war die Rückkehr von José Mourinho nach Italien. Wie wird das funktionieren? Und es funktioniert bisher sehr, sehr gut. Er ist dieser starke Mann, diese starke Figur, die auch medial in einem so heißen Highcamp-Pflaster wie Rom, das mit, glaube ich, eines der kompliziertesten in ganz Europa ist. Also da ist zwischen Himmel hoch jauchzend und zu Tode betrübt. Also das Umfeld ist wirklich sehr, sehr schwierig. Und da war genau so ein Mann, glaube ich, der Richtige. Der analysiert das auf sich, der kann das mit seiner Art, mit seiner Mourinho-Art einfach. Also das war für mich davor eigentlich schon klar, dass er in diesem Sinn genau der Richtige ist. Aber die Skepsis war davor, ja gut, Mourinho, Fußball, Roma, passt es. Und man muss echt sagen, in der ersten Spiele, die Roma spielten richtig ansehnlichen Offensivfußball.
Also da ist wahnsinnig viel.
Ja, ja, das kommen wir auch danach. Beim Tipp würde ich sagen, schaut euch mal ein Roma-Spiel an. Also da ist total viel Zug drin. Tammy Abraham ist ja vorne drin gekommen, wurde ja als J-Kurve-Mann geholt, hat schon funktioniert, schon sehr gut. Lorenzo Pellegrini, der Kapitän, spielt einen herausragenden Saisonstart. Also ich kann nur jedem kurz mal raten, geht mal kurz auf YouTube, gebt mal Pellegrini ein, 2-3 Tore allein in dieser Saison. Alle erste Sahne, technisch unfassbar, auch am Wochenende wieder ein Hackentor. Also der macht auch den nächsten Schritt. Und ja, wie gesagt, viel Offensivschwung, Mkhitaryan, Sanyolio ist ja zurück nach seinem zweiten Kreuzbandres, Shumudorov, den haben sie ja von Janoi geholt, der bringt viel Speed rein über die Außen, wird brutal angeschoben, was ihnen bis jetzt auch ein bisschen Defensivprobleme gebracht hat, weil sie wahnsinnig mutig angreifen und dann manchmal auch schon das öfteren in den Konter gelaufen sind, wie jetzt zu letztem Wochenende, wo sie erst mal verloren haben gegen Erlas Verona. Aber wirklich die Roma, da ist brutal viel Schwung drin, brutal viel Wucht und ja, wenn das Roma-Ambiente mal angezündet ist und das ist es jetzt, dann ist da auch einiges drin. Also die Roma macht großen Spaß.
Tja, Mensch, da kann man sich ja wirklich drauf freuen. Haben ja auch schon in der Champions League gegen Sofia gewonnen. Ja, es müsste die Champions League sein. Mein Gott, ich bin so raus aus dem Fußball. Nein, das ist die Conference League. WCL steht jetzt für Conference League. Mensch, ich hätte mir doch denken können, UCL ist doch die Champions League. Da hat ja auch, mein Gott, der Max. Aber wirklich, mit der EM habe ich so komplett meine Festplatte der letzten Saison gelöscht. Das hat man noch nicht erlebt. Also ich entschuldige mich sehr herzlich für diesen Vorpaar. Wir sind jetzt schon am Ende angekommen. Ich denke, das nächste Mal müssen wir auf jeden Fall auch über Atalanta, Lazio und noch ein paar andere sprechen. Und die Fiorentina, absolut. Auf jeden Fall auch über die. Gibt es neben der Roma noch eine Mannschaft, wo du sagst, da könnte man jetzt mal einschalten?
Ja, wirklich.
Drei Siege auch, Vincenzo und Tagliano. Das werden wir mal anders vertiefen. Ein ganz interessanter Trainer, der hat letztes Jahr zusammen mit Andrea Pirlo mit höchsten Noten einen Fußballlehrer abgeschlossen. Logischerweise waren die Blick hier alle auf Pirlo gerichtet. Aber Italiano hat mit Spezia letztes Jahr schon großartige Arbeit geleistet, ist jetzt zur Fiorentina gekommen und setzt das Nahtlos fort. Das ist eine erfrischende Mannschaft. Dusan Plauevic vorne drin. Der Name sagt vielleicht mittlerweile auch ein paar was. Ist für mich einer der aufstrebendsten Mittelstürmer in ganz Europa. 21 brutale Wucht, Tore, Tore. Erinnert sich ein bisschen an den jungen Edinson Cavani. Also die Fiorentina, wirklich sehr, sehr ansehnlich. Die spielt heute Abend auch gegen Inter. Das wirkliche 2 gegen 5, ein Spitzenspiel. Die Fiorentina kann man auf dem Settel haben. Noch ein kleiner Tipp am Wochenende ist das Romderby. Roma gegen Lazio, Mourinho gegen Maurizio Sarri. Das kann man sich auf jeden Fall anschauen.
Da könnte vielleicht was passieren. Oh man, dieses Jahr. Letzte Saison war es wirklich eine tolle Saison. In dieser Saison scheint es auch wieder sehr viele Geschichten zu geben. Ich hätte jetzt nur noch das Superlo. Aber das lassen wir, das vertageln wir mal. Das machen wir wannanders. Denn jetzt wollen wir an dieser Stelle über die Premier League sprechen. Mit Hendrik Buch heißt er. Ich freue mich sehr, dass er die ganze Zeit dabei war. Wenn ich mir allein mal das Tabellenbild angucke, dann hat sich da jetzt nicht so viel getan. Es gibt Mannschaften, die vorneweg marschieren. Das sind Chelsea, Liverpool und United. Mit kleinerem Abstand Manchester City. Das ist allerdings auch schon eine Weile so. Bei Arsenal hat sich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel verbessert. Und mittendrin sitzt aber noch auf Tabellenplatz 4 Brighton and Half Albion. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir mit denen starten wollen. Du darfst die Zügel in die Hand nehmen. Was waren die wichtigen Themen in der Premier League?
Wichtige Themen waren natürlich einen Transfer, den Man United getätigt hat zum Abschluss des Transfers. Da war ja noch ein Aldo.
Über den wir natürlich gerne sprechen können.
Ich starte auch gerne mit Brighton, weil ich die natürlich auch hervorgehoben hätte bei der Frage, welchen Verein man vielleicht so ein bisschen auf dem Schirm haben sollte, über den man nicht so viel weiß. Da ist Brighton auf jeden Fall das richtige Beispiel, die in der vergangenen Saison schon richtig gut Fußball gespielt haben unter Graham Potter, vergleichsweise junger englischer Trainer, mit dem man hier in England sehr viel zutraut, auch mittelfristig, vielleicht man größeren Verein zu übernehmen. Letzte Saison schon sehr, sehr gut in der Tabelle der Expected Goals. Der zufolge werden sie letzte Saison 6. oder 7. geworden, also hätten um Europa mitgespielt, haben aber A, die Tore nicht geschossen und B, dann zum Teil absurde Gegentore kassiert. Und das ist diese Saison nicht mehr so. Also man muss natürlich sagen, fünf Spiele sind erst gespielt, von daher werden die wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht in die Meisterschaft mitspielen, aber diese Saison schaffen sie es zumindest, dass sie ihre oft spielerische Überlegenheit eben auch in Tore und Ergebnisse umwandeln. Und enge Spiele gehen dann auch mal für Brighton aus. Das war jetzt am Wochenende gut zu besichtigen gegen Leicester, wo Leicester dann zwei Tore aberkannt wurden wegen Absides. Und Brighton hat dann mal gewonnen, auch durch einen Elfmeter. Also man sieht, es sind so diese tiny margins, wie man in England sagt, das sind diese wirklich engen Entscheidungen, die dann auch mal für Brighton ausgehen. Das war wie gesagt in der Vergangenheit nicht immer so. Und ja, der Mannschaft gelingt es jetzt, wirklich diese spielerische Klasse, die sie in der Vergangenheit schon hatten. Also gutes Pressing mit Ball, durchaus interessanter Offensivfußball. Das eben auch in Ergebnisse umzuwandeln. Und das interessanterweise, obwohl sich jetzt die Mannschaft gar nicht so stark verändert ist. Also sie haben jetzt nicht plötzlich den einen Spieler geholt und plötzlich passt alles. Sondern sie spielen eigentlich weitgehend mit der gleichen Mannschaft der Vor-Saison. Also Shane Duffy ist zurückgekommen, ein Verteidiger, der in der letzten Saison an Celtic ausgeliehen war, dort nicht glücklich geworden ist und ist jetzt zurück bei Brighton. Der ist extrem wichtig, also erstens für die Defensive, aber auch offensiv bei Standards zum Beispiel. Jetzt auch gegen Leicester, einen Elfmeter mehr oder weniger rausgeholt, hat auch schon ein Saisontor erzielt. Also das ist wichtig. Sie haben sich auf der linken Verteidigerposition verbessert, wo sie einen sehr interessanten Spieler geholt haben. Mark Kukureya heißt der, aus der Barca-Jugend ursprünglich, wenn ich mich nicht irre. Also das war die linke Verteidigerseite, die offene Flanke von Brighton, die haben sie geschlossen. Und dann haben sie mit Yves Bissouma im Mittelfeld, ein Spieler, der in der Vergangenheit schon gehandelt wurde, als einer, der irgendwann mal einen ganz großen Wechsel, einen ganz großen Transfer vollzieht, wird verglichen mit Golo Kante. Das ist einer der Schlüsselspieler bei Brighton. So ist es dann tatsächlich so, dass in diesen ersten fünf Spielen der Saison, wie gesagt, immer alles unter Einschränkung, aber dass dann plötzlich vieles, was in der letzten Saison nicht funktioniert hat, funktioniert dann plötzlich.
Und mittendrin ist Pascal Groß auch noch, den kennt man ja auch noch als deutscher Fußballfan vermutlich. Und man hat ja aber auch einen Abgang zu verzeichnen gehabt. Ben White ist zu Arsenal gewechselt, für gar nicht so kleine Münze innen Verteidiger. Also es scheint so zu sein, als könnte man das ganz gut über Spielstil und eben die von dir angenannten Rückkehrer oder Neuverpflichtungen auffangen.
Genau, also der Weckgang von Ben White macht es jetzt noch nicht so stark bemerkbar. Bei Arsenal kann man es auch noch nicht so sehen, dass er Arsenal maßgeblich verbessert hätte. Von daher sieht Brighton auf jeden Fall nicht wie der Verlierer dieses Transfers aus. Wie gesagt, die Rückkehr von Duffy spielt natürlich eine große Rolle, um die Abwehr zu stabilisieren.
Apropos Rückkehr, dann lass uns doch über Cristiano Ronaldo und Manchester United sprechen. Ein Kopf-an-Kopf-Rennen soll es gewesen sein, nach allem, was man inzwischen weiß. Zwischen City, wo es dann schon sehr weit aussah, und dann kam aber doch United zum Zug. Und jetzt ist er zurückgekehrt. Das wird auch so inszeniert, wie so etwas eben heutzutage inszeniert wird. Wenn wir jetzt mal das sportlich betrachten und das Spektakel weglassen, und dabei auch die eine oder andere Sache, die ihm noch anheft. Es gibt ja immer noch nicht geklärte Vergewaltigungsvorwürfe gegen ihn, rein sportlich gesehen. Was hat man denn bisher von ihm sehen können bei United?
Man hat eigentlich genau das sehen können und auch das nicht sehen können, was zu erwarten war. Also zu erwarten war, dass er sofort wichtig wird als Torschütze, dass er sofort Tore garantiert. Das tut er. Drei Spiele, vier Treffer, kann man nicht sagen. Auch alles klassische Mittelstürmer-Tore. Also wer sich die mal anschauen mag oder vielleicht auch gesehen hat, das waren jetzt alle Tore aus kurzer Distanz, wo jemals der Torwart nicht so wahnsinnig gut aussah. Also ich habe hier in einem Podcast, beim Guardian war es, die haben schon gescherzt, dass Ronaldo die Torhüter bestoffen hätte, damit er möglichst gut aussieht bei seiner Rückkehr. Also es sind schon klassische Mittelstürmer-Tore, die er schießt. Und das hat manche vorher gefehlt, es gab keinen verlässlichen Torschützen aus Mittelstürmer-Position. Und das bringt Ronaldo sofort. Was er eben nicht bringt, bzw. die problematischen Dimensionen dieses Transfers aus sportlicher Sicht, sind auch genau die, die man vorher erwartet hatte. Nämlich, dass er natürlich kein Spieler ist, der sich übermäßig ins Pressing einschaltet, dass er jetzt nicht wahnsinnig teamdienlich spielt, ohne Ball. Und dass er natürlich so ein, zwei Probleme schafft, was andere Spieler angeht und eben die Frage, wo man die dann einbaut. Also das Beispiel, was ja auch aus Bundesliga-Sicht interessant ist, ist natürlich Jadon Sancho, der bis zu Ronaldos Ankunft der Königstransfer war, an dem man lange gearbeitet hat, der dann kam für sehr viel Geld, also 85 Millionen Euro waren es dann ja ungefähr. Und der jetzt so ein bisschen schauen muss, wo er bleibt, weil Ole Gunnar Solskjaer, der United-Trainer, stellt in einem 4-2-3-1 auf. Im defensiven Mittelfeld setzt er auf Fred und Scott McTominay. Das ist nicht wahnsinnig überzeugend, aber das ist eben, dass du auf das Solskjaer vertraut. Links spielt dann Pogba, in der Mitte Bruno Fernandes. Vorne natürlich Ronaldo. Da bleibt im Grunde noch ein Platz im offensiven Mittelfeld für Sancho, Mason Greenwood, Marcus Rashford, wenn der wieder fit ist. Auch ein Spieler wie Jess Lingard, der jetzt gegen West Ham eingewechselt wurde und dann auch direkt ein Tor geschossen hat. Also das sind so ein bisschen die Probleme, die mit dieser Ronaldo-Verpflichtung einhergehen, dass für so Spieler wie eben Sancho plötzlich kein Platz mehr ist oder zumindest nicht mehr diesen klaren Weg in die Startelf gibt. Also er hat zuletzt öfter links gespielt, wo man eigentlich eher rechts gesehen hätte. Wie gesagt, Mason Greenwood ist eigentlich immer so der Spieler gewesen, von dem man dachte, dass ihm die Zukunft bei United gehört, als Nummer 9, als einzelne Spitze. Der spielt jetzt rechts. Also das ist alles ein bisschen kompliziert und bestätigt auch, glaube ich, diejenigen, die gesagt haben, dass der Ronaldo-Wechsel mittelfristig United eher schadet als nützt. Dass man sich eben sehr, sehr viele Baustellen im Team schafft. Und, das vielleicht auch noch kurz angemerkt, dieses Problem im defensiven Mittelfeld hat immer noch nicht gelöst. Also das wäre eigentlich die Position gewesen, wo United dringend hätte etwas tun müssen. Und wie gesagt, da setzt jetzt Social weiter auf McTominay und Fred. Und das ist nicht nur meiner Meinung nach sehr dünn.
Es gab ja auch ein spektakuläres 1 zu 2 gegen die Young Boys aus Bern in der Champions League unter der Woche. Und in der letzten Folge der Ligatur hat auch schon Uli Hebel sich ähnlich kritisch geäußert gegenüber Solskjaer. Wir werden das weiter verfolgen wollen. Es ist aber nicht zu viel Zeit nur auf United zu verlieren. Es gibt ja auch noch andere Mannschaften. Aktuell sind ja ebenfalls mit 13 Punkten vorne Chelsea und Liverpool. Aber Paul, wie gefallen dir denn die bisherigen Auftritte dieser beiden Mannschaften?
Ja, sehr gut, muss man sagen. Das ist jetzt keine wahnsinnig steile These. Also beide fünf Spiele noch ohne Niederlage. Bei Chelsea war es erwartet worden. Logischerweise Champions-League-Sieger mit Thomas Tuchel, ein Trainer, der wirklich auf das Optimus dieser Mannschaft herausholt und sich mit Romelu Lukaku noch mal verstärkt hat. Und auch so eine offene Flanke geschlossen hat, damit man jetzt auch einen Mittelstürmer hat, der auch Tore schießt. War ja bei Chelsea nicht immer so in der vergangenen Saison. Von daher, dass Chelsea da oben so weitgehend, oder mit ziemlich weiter Weste oben steht, das war zu erwarten gewesen. Bei Liverpool ist es ein bisschen überraschend, weil sich schon viele Leute gefragt haben nach der letzten Saison, die für Liverpool-Standards ziemlich enttäuschend war. Und nachdem man jetzt auch nicht groß eingekauft hat im Sommer, also Konati war der einzige Transfer, war so ein bisschen die Erwartung und die Befürchtung, dass das Liverpool abfällt, halt eben in der Chelsea, Man Utd, Man City. Und das ist bisher nicht zu sehen. Also Liverpool und Klopp hat seinen Mojo zurück, wie man jetzt hier mehrfach schon gelesen hat nach den letzten Spielen. Dazu trägt natürlich Beiderst und Virgil van Dijk wieder da, als der einfach der Schlüsselspieler in dieser Mannschaft ist. Dazu trägt die Rückkehr des Publikums, glaube ich, bei. Das ist natürlich ein Klischee, wenn man sagt, Liverpool ist besonders auf die Fans und auf Anfield und so weiter angewiesen. Und ich kann es auch nicht mehr hören, aber ich glaube, im Endeffekt kommt man um diesen Faktor einfach nicht drum rum. Und Liverpool kann jetzt ein bisschen, anders als in der letzten Saison, kann jetzt auch ein bisschen rotieren. Also in der Champions-Sequence war er gegen Milan, saß dann Van Dijk zum Beispiel mal draußen. Das war unproblematisch. Jetzt in der Liga zuletzt gegen Crystal Palace musste dann James Milner plötzlich rechts auf der rechten Abwehrseite spielen. Und James Milner ist ja ohnehin jemand, der so jegliche Rationalität, so ein bisschen entgegen jeglicher Rationalität ja immer noch da ist und immer noch seine Leistung bringt. Eigentlich egal auf welcher Position. Konade hat zum ersten Mal gespielt in der Premier League. Giorgi Giotta ist vorne sehr, sehr wichtig. Firmino ist noch so ein bisschen hinten dran. Also Liverpool kann jetzt auch mal so ein bisschen rotieren, was der Mannschaft sicher zugutekommt. Und von daher ist man jetzt mit 13 Punkten Punkt und auch Torgleich mit Chelsea. Also gleiche Anzahl an Toren geschossen. Zwölf gleiche Anzahl an Gegentoren. Chelsea liegt nur aufgrund der alphabetischen Reihenfolge. Also C, V, L auf Tabellenplatz 1. Ich weiß nicht, ob das am letzten Spiel auch so entschieden werden würde. Aber von daher, genau, die Mannschaften gleich auf. Beide gut anzuschauen. Und wie gesagt, bei Chelsea war es so ein bisschen erwartet worden. Bei Liverpool ist es eher überraschend. Und haben ja auch schon gegeneinander gespielt. Bei diesem durchaus spektakulären 1-1, wo Chelsea ja zu Zehnt dieses Remis verteidigt hat vor der Länderspielpause. Bei Liverpool muss man mal schauen, wenn jetzt die großen Gegner kommen. Also Anfang Oktober geht es gegen Man City. Dann kommt oder geht es gegen Man United. Also mal schauen, ob sie dann immer noch tatsächlich in Schlagdistance zur Tabellenspitze oder sogar in der Tabellenspitze stehen. Aber bislang muss man sagen, macht Liverpool das sehr, sehr gut. Und wie gesagt, aus Sicht vieler beobachter auch überraschend gut.
Ja, da waren wir auch durchaus etwas zurückhaltender in der letzten Sendung. Ist ja auch schön zu sehen, wenn man da positiv überrascht wird. Was ich auffällig finde mit Blick auf die Tabelle, ist, dass wir gleich drei Mannschaften haben, die erst ein Gegentor in fünf Liga-Spielen kassiert haben, nämlich Chelsea, Liverpool und Manchester City. Bei City fällt dann so ein bisschen das 6 zu 3 gegen Rasenball-Sport Leipzig raus. Wir haben hier in der Bundesliga ja viele Diskussionen, wenn Bayern mal wieder Bochum mit 7 zu 0 abfertigt, ob das nicht alles langweilig sei. Ist das jetzt ein Zufall? Also, dass die eine gute Verteidigung haben, das ist mir natürlich schon klar, aber ich finde, ein Gegentreffer nach fünf Spielen ist halt wirklich krass, wenn das mehrere Mannschaften schaffen. Ist das jetzt eben nur dem Spielplan geschuldet, oder würdest du sagen, man sieht halt schon einen Trend, dass die Schere der Big Six zu den anderen Vereinen auseinandergeht?
Naja, also Big Six, das muss man ja auch wieder so ein bisschen einschränken, weil die gibt es ja praktisch nicht mehr. Also Arsenal Spurs sind ja schon ein gutes Stück abgefallen, jetzt ja auch nicht erst in dieser Saison. Es gibt schon immer mal wieder die Diskussion, wenn Manchester City dann 5-0 gegen Norwich gewinnt oder in der Vorsaison 7-0 gegen Watford. Also das gibt es dann schon auch, dass das Gefälle zwischen den Top-Teams und den kleineren Teams der Premier League wirklich zu hoch ist. Was natürlich die Premier League auszeichnet im Vergleich zur Bundesliga, ist, dass du nicht nur einen Verein hast, der in der Lage ist, andere Vereine mal eben mit 4, 5, 6 Gegentoren abzufertigen, sondern im Zweifel halt mehrere Vereine. Und dass du halt immer noch nicht nur einen Verein hast, der Meister werden kann und dann vielleicht so 1, 2 Konkurrenten, sondern du hast halt 3, 4 Vereine. Und ich glaube, dass diese Konstellation, und wo die Premier League auch sehr, sehr stolz drauf ist, diese hohe Competitiveness, dass das oft so ein bisschen darüber hinwegtäuscht, dass es natürlich doch ein klares Leistungsgefälle in der Premier League gibt.
Und gibt es da abschließend eine Mannschaft, wo du sagst, die fällt da raus? Also, wen gibt es so in der Premier League, wenn du jetzt sagst, du darfst jetzt noch über ein Team reden, dann schneide ich mit dir das Mikrokabel durch. Und es soll vielleicht keiner von den bekannten Namen sein oder von den Namen, die einen sofort einfallen. Gibt es da eine Mannschaft, die dir sofort in den Sinn kommt?
Ich hätte natürlich Brighton genannt, aber die haben wir schon besprochen. Von daher will ich gerne auf Aston Villa hinweisen, die ich extrem interessant finde. Also erstens, weil es ein großer Club ist mit einem großen Umfeld, großer Tradition, Wahnsinnsstadion auch. Und die ja aber im Sommer bekanntermaßen den besten Spieler verloren haben, Jack Grealish, für 100 Millionen Pfund. Und das sind ja ungefähr 118 Millionen Euro an Manchester City. Wo natürlich die Befürchtung groß war, ob jetzt Aston Villa auseinanderfällt. Und die haben aber meiner Meinung nach wahnsinnig gut eingekauft, dieses Geld wahnsinnig gut investiert. Leon Bailey aus Leverkusen, Danny Ings, ein klassischer Torjäger von Southampton. Und Emiliano Buendia von Norwich, der Abstand besten Spieler der 2. Liga in der vergangenen Saison. Und Aston Villa ist 10. Also die spielen jetzt auch noch nicht die Sterne vom Himmel. Aber ich finde es trotzdem interessant zu beobachten, wie sich dieser Verein weiterentwickelt. Leon Bailey hat jetzt, gerade am Wochenende gegen Everton, einen ziemlich beeindruckenden Einsatz hingelegt, das eingewechselt wurde. Nach einer Stunde hat ein Eigentor per Ecke mehr oder weniger provoziert, hat ein Tor selbst geschossen, und ist dann nach 20 Minuten verletzt wieder ausgewechselt worden. Also das ist auch wirklich sehr, sehr effizient, dieser Kurz-Einsatz gewesen. Und ich finde, Aston Villa ist ein Verein, den man auf jeden Fall im Blick behalten sollte, eben wegen des Gülisch-Abgangs, aber auch eben der Lösung, die sie dann gefunden haben, um dieses Geld zu reinvestieren.
Henrik, wie schätzt du den Western United ein? Die haben in den letzten Jahren, auch, glaube ich, einen Schritt nach vorne gemacht. Ich sage es deswegen auch, weil ein Freund von mir ist Tschechien, da spielen, glaube ich, jetzt zwei, drei tschechische Nationalspieler. Und mit Pablo Fornals haben sie auch einen, der beim FC Malaga mal gespielt hat, der da, glaube ich, auch im Moment ziemlich an Feier ist. Wie schätzt du die Hammers ein?
Ja, total interessanter Verein. Und die Tschechen, die du angesprochen hast, also Soufal und Suchek, waren in der letzten Saison tatsächlich die entscheidenden Spieler. Zusammen dann mit Trainer David Mois, der sich so ein bisschen rehabilitiert hat, weil er nach seinem gescheiterten Engagement bei Man United als Witzfigur, muss man tatsächlich sagen, in England angesehen wurde. Der aber tatsächlich West Ham stabilisiert hat und ja auch zu Recht in die Europa League geführt hat. Das Problem ist jetzt, dass einer der wichtigsten Spieler der letzten Saison war, ja auch Jess Lingard, der jetzt zurück zu Manchester United gegangen ist und jetzt auch direkt gegen West Ham das Siegtor geschossen hat passenderweise. Aber ich glaube, die Gefahr, dass die jetzt wirklich abfallen und irgendwie Richtung Abstiegskampf oder so, wo sie in den vergangenen Jahren oft waren, wieder rutschen, die sehe ich nicht. Also die sind jetzt Achter und da glaube ich, da wird sich West Ham auch einpennen. Und das ist dann auch für West Ham verhältnisvoll.
Sehr gut. Haben wir schon deinen TV-Tipp, hatten wir den schon erwähnt? Oder wen würdest du empfehlen, bei welcher Mannschaft sollte man einschalten bei der Premier League?
Ich dachte, das wäre schon die Frage nach den kleineren Clues. Das wäre schon der TV-Tipp gewesen. Nein, das ist total in Ordnung. Man kann sich natürlich Brandford immer anschauen. Die sind spannend. Aufgestiegen mit einem interessanten Pressing-Stil. Wenn sie den Ball haben, auch sehr ansehnlich nach vorne. Spielend mit einem absoluten Ausnahmestürmer. Ivan Tony, Torschützenkönig der Champions-Chip in der vergangenen Saison. Wahnsinnig sicherer Elfmeterschützer. Das hat er jetzt auch bewiesen. Im letzten Spiel gegen die Wolves. Brandford 5 Spiele, erst eins verloren. Die werden die Saison wahrscheinlich die Rolle einnehmen von Leeds United in der letzten Saison. Der interessante Aufsteiger, der sich wahrscheinlich relativ komfortabel in der Liga halten wird.
Von denen hat ja auch schon Uli Hebel in der letzten Folge auch schon vorgeschwammt. Also da gebt ihr euch die Hand.
Genau, ist ja auch der Verein, der auf dieses Moneyball-Prinzip setzt. Das muss man wahrscheinlich bei Brandford auch immer einmal erwähnt haben. Auf diesen ganz speziell datenbasierten Scouting-Ansatz. Und das klappt bislang gut. Haben auch einen deutschen Spieler, Italiener, U21-Europameister, der dort Stammspieler ist im defensiven Mittelfeld. Also, die kann man sich auf jeden Fall anschauen. Ist ein interessanter Verein. Wenn wir jetzt schon über die deutschen Connections sprechen, möchte ich mal ganz kurz Norwich erwähnen, Norwich City. Kann man sich auch immer anschauen. Da fallen auch immer viele Tore, allerdings meistens für den Gegner. Also, Norwich fünf Spiele, fünf Niederlagen, Kawellenletzter. Das besteht die große Gefahr, dass sie da auch bleiben.
14 Gegentreffer bisher. Hendrik, ganz herzlichen Dank an dich. Ganz herzlichen Dank an euch alle. In Abwesenheit danke ich David Frogier de Ponlevoy et un gungung vn auf Twitter. Ich werde natürlich alle Twitter-Handles und Namen wie immer in die Show-Notes packen. Da könnt ihr den Gästen hier folgen. Und danke dann sehr herzlich in Reihenfolge des Erscheinens. Fabian Pakulat werde ich natürlich auch verlinken. Danke dir, Fabian, dass du mit dabei warst. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Ich freue mich schon. Dann Christian Bernhard. Danke dir, Christian, für deine Zeit. Und zuletzt natürlich Hendrik Buchheister. Vielen Dank, dass du uns den Blick auf die Insel erleichtert hast. Danke dir, Hendrik. Und euch lieben Hörern und Hörern, danke fürs Zuhören. Lasst gerne Feedback da im Forum und in den sozialen Netzwerken, wie euch jetzt diese Form der Ligatur gefallen hat. Länge ist ein bisschen ein Problem, aber andererseits haben wir auch viel erfahren. Ich bin gespannt, wie ihr das alles findet. Und dann schauen wir einfach, wie wir das weitermachen im Rasenfunk. In diesem Sinne, wir sind allein Hörerinnen und Hörer finanziert. Unterstützt uns gerne, rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Und dann hören wir uns in der nächsten Woche wieder. Bis dahin, macht's gut.